All feels really good to me ray
That one's business pigs huh? I think we're gonna be real comfortable here. Yeah, me, too
It's all banned finally went and sold the place you usually run hotels no, I'm an electrician. I just wanted to try something different
That's tens of pitch I'll take him
That's her isn't it she was our first guest?
The boys over the gas stations have you filled out of your parking lot pretty fast everybody knows everybody around here except you
Did you do it ?
Did I do what? Did you do it?
You're with that girl the night she died. I saw you at my place. You have watch that it
See anybody well, why would I watch your place? You told me ! This is a crime we could lose the motel
Did you do it? Did I do Daisy do it?
Thank you, what did you see?
Did you see something ray
You